aie aie aie aie coup dur pour les sens
ça marche on n'était pas en live et
celui-ci en live on est en live si
ceux-là il mais c'est de trouver notre
stabilité écoute les médias locaux il
faut bien bien alors est-ce que ça va
mais on est dans un endroit particulier
on est dans une fonction estivale
les utopiales règles et roland lehoucq
il a fait une présentation c'est pas
trop tôt j'avais déjà en attaque les
saisies questions sociales on peut se
donner des contraintes par exemple
sébastien ne parle qu'en phrase
interrogative
moi j'ai fait un petit pas mais un
probable de les suivre et du coup il
vous faut des gants
c'est ce que j ai à quelqu'un mais moi
je fais mon rôle c'est un contrat qui va
dire baisse tout en braille contre
imported vraiment faire un axe bien nous
présentiez si chacun d'entre vous devez
beach en 30 secondes ce qui fait sur sa
chaîne réciproque de la personne a droit
à deux pas de pitié la chaîne de la
personne c'est parti la loi n'oblige
personne du coup tu vas pitié ce
monsieur là allez bonne génération est
au moins sûr de la prescience quoi
passer l'émotion séparés de toi moi je
présente quelqu'un mais je me présente
et sébastien carrasso mais un jour n'a
plus besoin de le présenter gaulle est
vraiment trop connu le sense of wonder
mesdames et messieurs la chaîne de
référence en a trop francophone
anglophone être annoncé très bon contenu
on regrettera par contre la fréquence à
laquelle sortent les vidéos c'est tendu
remis laërt sa terre et le conflit
et puis non en attendant justement la
patience paye finalement que ce matin et
là le contenu arrive la vidéo ben ça
cartonne dans les yeux franchement
abonnés je suis menacé mais voilà vous
avouer studio alors je sais pas si cette
salle est assez grande pour mon melon
que je viens de prendre
ok donc valentine sciences de comptoir
elle fait des vidéos c'est à dire des
successions l'image animée
il y en a à peu près 24 par seconde elle
fait du conflit avec de la musique et
des paroles souvent en c'est du contenu
assez incarner honteux qu'on te voir sur
des images en couleur résolution
technologie derrière
du coup est-ce qu'on peut te voir pour
te voir sur youtube sur youtube
plateforme bien connue des gaffes
ab science est un truc sur des questions
non d'accord c'est pour ça que ça
coulait comme des braves et le cynisme
et écouter ce que te plutôt sur du 24
images par seconde monte pas plus
maputo dont cinq gars non mais moi je te
suis arrêté à des vidéos à 24 oui bah
ouais donc les caisses en seconde
donc les de la chaîne voilà qui est
aussi de la chaîne zeta bike et wanted à
semarang discuter tout à l'heure dans le
train 2 comment présenter les et que sa
présentation devait durer à peu près
trois minutes forcément tout ce que ça
fait d'être mathématicien philosophe
cuisinier voilà un décorateur de lits
multimoteur randonneurs merci moi je
vais présenter
tivo qui est auteur de la chaîne axione
dix mille abonnés des vidéos de trois
heures pour présenter avec un excellent
présentateur qu'on ne présente plus les
voici
mais honnêtement non photo ct scan la
thématique de la chaîne tu vois ça comme
le disait non représentés - y'a pas de
problème
moi je peux te présenter en ce moment tu
faisais sous ce nom le savons tous que
les bailleurs là ils ont avec une
citation de comme disait lavoisier tous
france en août à quitter l'irak de façon
responsable
non pas tout à fait c'est quoi ce rendez
vous juste chaîne twitch widgets tweet
maintenant un monsieur d'une interview
par özil mais ma présentation parce que
une interview par semaine d'une heure
une heure et demie
conférence par semaine avec un chercheur
d'une chercheuse différents et c'est
génial fin vraiment c'est des jeunes
chercheurs qui vous parle sur
directement sur tweets et [ __ ] quoi
une conférence de vulgarisation sur
twitter par semaine j'aime ça yatuu
teruel hurler sa merde oui surtout le
plein je suis un peu un imposteur ici
par rapport aux statistiques au bout
nombre de chez normal tu vois si j'étais
là il y avait corner
on s'inquiète pas il n'ya pas tendre
avec sa f10 me dire actionner les
gentils peu de l'esprit auront saisi la
référence était de retour stream deux
otages
donc c'était un très bon tour de
pitchouns
je suis désolé mais qui est heureuse
alors conscience de la vente qui suis je
suis un jeune docteur qui s'intéresse
beaucoup à la médiation et je fais des
tout par ci par là à droite à gauche
qu'est ce que tu fais à gauche du coup à
gauche perd collectif conscient même
parlé à droite là je vais aider mes
propres réseaux sociaux surtout sur
twitter tu construis réseau social à ses
fins sociales basé sur on s'intéresse
aux micros cachés sur le réseau social
fait la lumière sur des petites choses
qu'on voit pas littéralement
certains voient là et c'est de faire
prendre connaissance aux gens qu'il ya
des choses belles à voir sans nos yeux
est que peuvent être potentiellement
utiles
je souligne aux technologies ou des eaux
ou potentiellement rien du tout à sa
gauche et à droite et qu'est ce que tu
as à l'extrême gauche
et ont été ou étaient ouverts et théo je
fais tout et je suis un angle président
qui on a quelques drops il ya des
problèmes de l'image sur 10 les gens qui
nous écoutent ils nous regardent l'arche
dites nous si vous ratez des fins de
faim de blagues faudrait rappeler un
moment donné c'est sûr de ce que les
gens qui prennent jamais comprendre le
faire voilà donc j'ai comme comme disait
[Musique]
comme défi de ne pas terminer t et
qu'elle et autres défis alors sébastien
doit toujours faire des phrases à la
forme pas du tout et vous de on n'a pas
trop bien moi je n'avais pas de très
mauvais pour les défis parce que ce sont
des métaphores des comparaisons partout
tu m'aimes tu vas par image des gens qui
parlent en dessinant j'ai pas de
compassion des leaks ni baez
la police n'est ce pas le bleu et noir
serait déjà pas mal
ni le guide vivant comme ça ça va
saturer donc pas bon donc j'ai pas de
contrat que sita contrainte ça pourrait
être de parler et de légendes pas décidé
dans le public est ce que maintenant une
idée peut-être si vous avez un tas donné
et je peux parler avec l'accent
québécois ont leur page perso je veux
dire l'eau h 2 non on est combien ils
sont bien sûr vous avez 9 de plus que
d'habitude je pense comme papillon j'ai
passé popian le soleil c'est the place
to be les ramener aux mutins mais j'ai
fait pas faire ce genre de twitter avait
besoin de létalité moi c'est clair on va
galérer avec vos contraintes plus rage
si vous voulez me voir pas finir mes
phrases rejoignez le live du marché noir
où tout le monde est sur son téléphone
non mais 20h05 rollover
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ou pas qu'est ce
que vous faites des médiateurs de talent
mais qu'est ce que vous faites
je pense qu'on est sur un live du
collectif ont fait un tour de main voyez
anniversaire sébastien québécois craint
québécois tunisienne de fête du jeu au
québec aussi bonne tête
je suis tellement content que tu m'as
trognon mais je pense qu'ils pourraient
demander à viviane sera confirmé les
gens sont des surveillants les gens qui
sont là sont donc
oui donc qu'est ce que je vais dire -
pourquoi vous êtes dit on va venir faire
confiance au plaisir que ça etc de quoi
vous avez parlé d'ailleurs mais on sait
qu'on a fait le même sujet c'est la
convergence évolutive c'est pas
concertés donc on a en fait on a parlé
d'exobiologie à des moments différents
donc les gens ont pu d'abord assisté à
mâcon puis à la tienne et à prendre les
mêmes choses non en réalité tu avais tu
as fait des choses un peu différentes
moi j'ai fait seulement de poser des
souhaits et désirs ou les clubs de logis
je finis quand même je finis exobiologie
la science qui s'intéresse à l'origine
de la vie sur terre et la possible
existence de vie ailleurs
extraterrestres ont pas voilà je devais
juste aujourd'hui une petite conflit
dessus les toits du couturier ont aussi
parlé d'exobiologie mais tu es allé un
peu plus loin
tourné dans l'histoire de la terre
d'univers j'ai parlé de l'histoire de
l'humanité dans son contexte cosmique je
crois juste du 3gs mais c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile as que de nous poser
que des questions assez horrible je sais
pas penser comme ça mais c'était
horrible merci au jeu des clips
personnage du temps à saint louis qui
fait ça c'est facile bien avec ça mais
j'ai dit oui bien sûr c'est que si oui
ou non je suis troisième étuve à leur
métier un plaisir de tous que c'est ben
écoute c'est un plaisir de m'avoir aussi
parce que tu sais que le nom stéphane il
s'agit bien de son projet
oh la la alors vous pouvez trouver sur
le site du collectif conscience qui
collectif conscience point org
on change tout ok voilà donc il ya un
onglet si phallus avec un magazine à la
base c'est un magazine mensuel et au
magazine de vulgarisation scientifique
entièrement bénévoles qui ont des
numéros
le premier sur un club bien sûr il ya la
lumière et le deuxième sur l'eau et le
troisième est en cours sur les animaux
et depuis dix ans mais sortir un jour un
jour dont 10 sortira un jour où tu sais
vous voulez noir fait pression sur des
nantis et surtout je vous remercie
d'avoir fait prospérer le nom grâce à
votre manière de suivre en temps on
collabore en taxi merci merci pour ton
super talent vient pas la nation sont là
ce jeu même nom est très fier bien loin
il a alors posé des questions récemment
vu récemment vulgarisateur a parlé de
gary de temps à parler de coïncidence et
vos petits de convergence convergence
révolution n'a de coïncidences évolutif
dans le mieux dans un milieu semblables
des espèces qui pourraient présenter des
traits communs c'est trop long
convergence ndiaye suggéré espèces après
suggérer quelque part qu'il existe des
humanoïdes bipèdes cerveau de danse et
c'est dans ces termes est ce qu'on fait
bien des gens comme vous
mais ailleurs ce que j'intéresse entrant
en amour oui question au mauvais
vraiment au moins cet endroit parce
qu'on a aucun biologiste au tournoi à
six si on a on à renault oui est-ce que
tu viendrais pas coutume c'est que il y
avait quelqu un je ne sais plus qui qui
avait popularisé l'idée que vu que
l'homme aujourd'hui sur terre il est
quand même une des espèces qui a le plus
c'est un peu le plus discipliné sur la
terre on peut imaginer que si on prend
en considération que c'est un peu j'aime
pas dire ça la plus sélectionné et la
plus avantageuse de doute on peut
imaginer retrouver quelque chose
semblable à nous sur une autre planète
ça c'est un monsieur qui s'appelle simon
conway morris
merci a écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle
the crucible of creation et qui est
aussi un énorme gâteau ni objection a
sévi dans sa mère si elles mêmes
conditions voilà c'est ça mais on parle
de convergence évolutive et dans donc
cities est bien dans un milieu
semblables des espèces qui pourrait pas
non il n'avait pas précisé mais je pars
du principe que si on a une pleine car
son oui bah si on veut supprimer ce
canon mais l'annoncé nous arrange parce
que s'il ya trop gravité on se croit
tout petit écraser toute la saveur des
courriers ça dépend il ya plein de
théories comme ça on la théorie des
multivers par exemple une infinité
d'univers et puis il ya peut-être un
univers où les parle avec un accent ou
les gens disent oh je sais pas si ça
existe mais
je pense que je vais revenir je pense
que je le redirai chez mugler
j'étais parti en fait on a demandé
qu'est ce qu'ils venaient faire ici et
maintenant à l'amendé va demander avec
deux que vous connaissez bien d'ailleurs
s'il est venu d'ailleurs faire des trucs
aussi en collaboration ici priori non
mais dans la toile un truc ensemble ce
matin papale avec avec ses avec ses deux
cents également on était habillée quand
ça tourne est fait et je pense demain on
va faire comme une émission le premier
jeu télé mobilisés selon la formule deux
pays'' de fun un mauvais point québécois
j'ai le droit d'utiliser bio 2 on est
sur la création en direct du tgv coup et
beck haas est ce que c'est le klaxon
j'ai des amis québécois qu'ils ont dit
que c'était comme pop hirawi on a tous
des amis mon message passe on a comme
vous donner des conférences
comme pour les deux randonnées les
algorithmes robustement bénédicte le
journal qu'à chaque fois que les prend
un accent québécois on gagne un follower
continue mais 0e bonsoir du québec bien
je passe au québécois n'aura pas pesé
lourd et donc une conférence aussi sur
sur le paradoxe de newcombe que c'est un
paradoxe avec nous a expliqué oui si je
me lance dans mes savoir le très court
tout au fond de la rationalité
voilà on a beaucoup parlé sur l'action
une autre chaîne ces marchés c'est sa
chaîne principale
[Musique]
amy dans les com amzn you monde voit la
vitesse n'a pas dit ce que tu venais
faire ici toi tu veux tenter en sans
finir sa phrase
bah je fous bombay dont soneb ok alors
du coup lorsque sont marrant c'est que
tous autour de la table il ya plein de
manières de fabrication totalement
différentes et avec des gens c'est à
dire qu'on va avoir le kotéba live
conférence on a le côté très posé de
s'abattre tactique on va jouer plus tôt
cet automne et 13 bars et de valentine
les je vois pas cette vidéo je suis
désolé mais moi j'ai regardé le kotéba
l'assaut dans les montagnes pour
discuter réjouissante voilà c'est déjà
ce qui tue les gens et en plus bien que
je ne verrai de monde finalement une
troupe du monde après une journée de
deuil
si léonard pour tapis très la vidéo
parce que mon avis ça va être un fameux
chapitre était oui les gens tu vas tu
mets de base
récemment mais si on n'a pas fait ça sur
l'actualité c'est pas tant de différence
alors pourquoi vous choisissez ce mode
de là et où sept en quelques mots
pourquoi vous vous choisissez ce mode de
médiation là et pas un autre
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans le dans le
créneau la montagne ça vous gagne
fermées la nuit
donc non bah moi je c'est vrai que je
mon projet récent là c'était les lie sur
sur twitch et pourquoi je me suis mis à
faire ça parce que j'ai trouvé que ça
existait pas forcément du côté
francophone du moins ça existe un petit
peu côté anglophone côté américain il ya
des gens qui se mettent à faire des live
où il parle comme ça sans s'arrêter de
l'un de leurs connaissances le gallou
vent juste google maps est en fait ils
expliquent la seconde guerre mondiale et
les forces en opposition en montrant les
déplacements des troubles mais juste
avec très peu d'outils une caméra et et
un navigateur internet quoi bon c'est
vachement intéressant enfin ils voient
qu'il ya des gens qui sont intéressés il
ya un public qui s'intéresse à ce genre
de questions je me dis pourquoi ça
n'existe pas en france et pourquoi pas
essayer de développer le côté médiation
scientifique sur twitch sans que
twitchell à une plate forme
principalement de jeux vidéo mais que ça
commence à se diversifier il ya aussi de
plus en plus d'activités différentes
autres que le jeu vidéo et les gens
aiment bien ce contact avec les les
autres avec le streamer discuter de
sujets de tout et n'importe quoi et donc
diffuser la connaissance ça pourrait
aussi marcher je pense sur twitter
je me suis mis à faire c'est live et
mais bon comme je suis pas connaisseur
sur tous les sujets pour avoir quelque
chose de pérenne et qui tienne il faut
que j'invite un invité faut que j'invite
quelqu'un qui puisse simplement parler
d'un sujet qu'il connaît bien et qui a
envie de communiquer de vulgariser
auprès du grand public
de telle sorte à ce que chaque émission
on a des nouvelles connaissances
apportées par un expert ce soit fiable
et que ce soit intéressant voilà bon là
ça mène son petit bonhomme de chemin
manière très modeste mais voilà j'ai
déjà envie de voir que ça évolue
ouais bah j'ai eu la chance de faire
partie des premiers comme vous justement
qu'ils ont c'est un petit peu l'ancien
même moment à vrai dire je me suis même
lancée après vous avoir vu fait c'était
une idée que j'avais j'avais plusieurs
mois avant mais j'avais la flemme de la
lancer un premier live et souvent il
faut une étincelle il faut qu'il ya un
autre truc dans l'environnement qui te
lances et la série veut ça a été votre
première période je suis dit on va
essayer ce lens faut que je fasse un
truc faut que j'arrête de juste être sur
la théorie où j'avais préparé les scènes
logiciel machin j'avais plus une excuse
avant les ce que c'était que j'étais en
thèse est donc je n'avais pas le temps
mais la bataille qui oppose d'un gp j'ai
un peu plus de temps donc qu'est
objectifs de ce live
l'objectif c'est de parler de science et
de médiation tous ensemble avec des gens
cool et dans la bonne humeur et avec des
contraintes riscle et c'est ce à quoi se
poser très barré
je n'ai pas du tout non non non pas
toujours méfiant juste vraiment pas dit
ils ont fait de gagner dans les perdants
mais non pas parce que c'est rigolo de
rigoler vidéo wii vidéo sur la rigologie
non pas parce que c'est mieux de faire
passer des sciences en rigolant et puis
ça permet de toucher un autre public
voilà éduquer et ses suites les hippies
ou la georgie dit que ça ferait mieux
passer la pilule parce que c'est quand
même assez difficile d'aller voir une
chaîne de géologie estairois où tout sur
le granit du phallus pas tout ouais du
coup on idée c'est un peu de
dépoussiérer l'image qu'on peut avoir de
la géologie et montre que c'est fini
science sas est là mais on en a parlé
comme lors du premier acte on a reçu
hier
et justement savez c'est un truc on pas
juste vu qu'elle avait dit à la fête de
la science
je suis dans une nuit dans un domaine
c'était ma critique et s'était mis côté
entre comme ça j'en vois qu'on en ait
parlé et c'est vrai que c'était marrant
de voir que d'avoir son avis en tout cas
dessus abriel cissé lequel vous pourrez
des études de biologie
qu'est ce qui est intéressant mais
qu'elle attendait les ché c'est drôle
parce que j'ai au départ c'est juste
parce que au lycée dans les cours de svt
j'étais pas dégoûté par la géologie gens
je supportais ça alors que mais tous mes
camarades était genre c'est nul et du
coup je me suis dit moi je peux être
continuer vers cette voie un peu tiède
crede avantages comparatifs dans
l'absence de dégoût voilà les nôtres
la géologie du budget continuer là
dedans et du coup j'ai découvert des
trucs assez chouette genre et voilà
chose on est tous d'accord donc mais en
fait je suis une grosse bosse triste
parce que j'ai arrêté après la licence
en géologie et j'ai bifurqué je suis
revenu dans le chemin j'ai fait de la
bio non alors autant dire que la
médiation est pourquoi je commençais ma
main j'ai commencé à faire des québécois
j'ai commencé à vulgariser à sion la
médiation de saborder l'émission
quelques lapins s'inspire des idées là
ces deux leviers alors bloquez pas sûr
qu'il ya des inégalités deux bouts d'eux
on arrête avec le pont serait bien qu'on
s'adapte on peut passer des informations
lors cela n'est pas avec moi pour ça
c'est dit en regardant mes vidéos je
suis pas là pour donner l'information
donc les j'ai commencé à bloguer en 2012
quand j'ai fait au québec
et puis après comme tout le monde le
sait les blogs ça n'explose pas et à
côté de ça chez certains ça fait moins
de vue que dès que des vidéos youtube et
du coup bas pour toucher plus de venger
une gt tous ceux qui qui qui sont ces
sur youtube et j'ai lancé ma prochaine
d'abord en anglais et savait pas
d'épaulé et puis après j'ai des frissons
en français et puis après j'ai rejoint
le puck qui cherchait quelqu'un pour
faire de la communication scientifique
c'était super bien on est maintenant
j'ai beaucoup de projets différents de
vulgarisation en explorant différents
formats et c'est très intéressant de
voir si toutes ces diversités bois
double stricte aurait notamment exigé
plusieurs chaînes youtube avec notamment
le pfl qui sont des trucs qui vont de ma
chaîne sport qui on peut naviguer
relation classique de youtube j'ai envie
de dire après des trucs beaucoup plus
scolaire la validera des trucs son
plaisir est impérieux de chercheurs
commentaire d'hier sont aux états bytes
et puis j'ai aussi d'autres trucs que
depuis format podcast et aussi avec vous
interviews des gens alors mauvaise
nouvelle pour ceux qui adorent
probablement peut-être mais je pense
qu'il y avoir beaucoup moins d'épisodes
probablement dans l'année qui vient
parce que je me lance dans d'autres
projets encore vraiment l'air en ce
moment chez une autre podcast récemment
qui sait qu'elle est plus sur les titres
de l'ia mais c'est en anglais et c'est
beaucoup de proches de la recherche très
accessible l'idée c'est vraiment de
présenter qu'est ce qui doit être fait
il pas juste avoir un constat des
problèmes et puis sinon qu'il écrit des
livres récemment vivre c'est très
intéressant si je le perds ta promo donc
voilà il ya un qui s'appelle la formule
du savoir qui vous explique comment
savoir parce que toutes les autres
méthodes ces dernières et debise surtout
la place
et non il ya des bras vraiment pis
théologique à ces quelques questions et
bonne façon de savoir il ya une approche
qui a été vraiment proposé par la place
qui a plus de 100 ans qui font des
vraiment sûr sur les probabilités
c'est une approche qui a ensuite était
beaucoup oublié puis reprise récemment
et sur lesquelles il ya beaucoup de très
bonnes propriétés mathématique peut
montrer que cette fait énormément de
propriété ça correspond pas mal à une
certaine intuition il ya des liens avec
les sciences cognitives mais il ya aussi
des énormes limite aux bases à nice
notamment en termes de puissance de
calcul parce que ça demande beaucoup de
calculs et met donc voilà donc le livre
parle vraiment d'une forme pure de
balises animations et une puissance de
calcul infini avec beaucoup de très
bonnes propriétés et puis après ça parle
de bon ben maintenant qu'on a des
puissances de calcul fini que ce soit
notre cerveau ou dans nos machines
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme très
bonne approximation de faire des bonnes
appréciations de ça ce qui est désolé
stick on peut utiliser un terreau du
niveau du cerveau humain basse et ses
premiers pas le deuxième livre c'est qui
qui est sorti il ya quelques mois
s'appelle le fabuleux chantier rendre
intelligent sartre chelle robustement
bénéfique ça parle beaucoup en fait de
l'algorithme et de youtube qui sont
affichées à une influence assez énorme
puisque sa touche de 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs à raison de 30 minutes
par jour ce qui vont énorme et du coup
la question qu'on pose c'est comment est
ce qu'on fait en sorte pour que les
recommandations de l'algorithme à coup
quelqu'un cherche train ou vaccination
ou aux changements climatiques sur
youtube comment est ce qu'on fait pour
proposer des vidéos qui sont bénéfiques
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de fausses
bonnes idées qu'on pourrait avoir
on parle un peu de tout ça c'est surtout
souligné fait qu'il ya besoin de
beaucoup plus de recherches pour
comprendre quels sont les impacts des
recommandations
de vidéos youtube c'est un peu un appel
à plus de plusieurs recherches mais
aussi certaines initiation à cette façon
de penser
donc il le podcast lancé récemment
s'appelle robin slip bénéficiant donc
robust les bénévoles sas russe sassou
sur youtube ça sauve sur itunes
associons rss si vous avez une api
podcast sur téléphone vous pouvez le
trouver aussi dit monsieur oui c'est
quoi qui sont derrière la question c'est
pourquoi c'était de l'humour est
pourquoi tu mais pourquoi tu as ce type
de médiation genre cette méthode là en
tout cas et ce style là et comment tu es
mieux la médiation aussi d'accord alors
j'étais prof à la base donc finalement
être prof au lycée ça ressemble ou pas
faire de la vulgarisation de philosophie
déjà puisque finalement baliser la fille
connaissent rien et donc fuller et on va
pas très loin mais on essaie d'être
accessible et voilà c'est ce qu'on parle
à des des enfants de 17 ans à des petits
combats de base quoi il en va de baghaï
voilà c'est ça compte vraiment c'est
exactement comme le public sur youtube a
priori qui connaîtraient pas forcément
la tueuse de fille qui essaie de parler
au début je voulais vraiment faire mal à
une gradation de traite ce niveau là
mais en fin de compte ça s'est vite
aller vers de la libération un peu plus
poussé mais globalement la fibre
vulgarisatrice j'étais un peu acquise en
faisant des cours au lycée c'était
c'était vachement bien de ceux conduits
là et ça s'est bien passé n'est pas
toujours facile non c'est pas c'est pas
génial je n'étais pas fan de ce
globalement donne des cours au lycée
le bon côté de recettes et de préparer
ensemble des cours
sur l'année c'est vraiment donner des
idées sur presque tous les champs la
philosophie et ça m'a donné aussi dire
un sens de la pédagogie par rapport à
toutes ces gens là que de filles parce
que pour réussir à faire quelque chose
qui accroche dès l'âge de 17 ans ainsi
tu y arrives tu peux réussir à accrocher
des effets commencent c'est quoi ta
recette secrète pour arriver à part
accroché site en a pas je sais quoi ce
que tu préfères juste pour capter leur
attention que j'y vas y ça va être
compliqué aussi de garder une attention
sur ce genre de sujet je sais pas une
bonne dose d'humour fois ça ça aide
quand même pas mal mais est aussi par
rapport à la philo par rapport à
d'autres proches je pense que je faisais
beaucoup moins dix heures de la
philosophie que beaucoup de profs de
philo et je pense que c'est une bonne
approche de d'avoir plutôt une approche
à partir des problèmes en fait venir à
fiuggi c'est avant tout un ensemble de
problèmes de questions et d'orienter les
choses autour de ça sans forcément avoir
une obsession sur le fait de bien rendre
la pensée de tel ou tel moteur donc je
pense que ça c'est une bonne façon
d'aborder la philosophie et il n'y a pas
de grandes bandes qui faisaient de la
philosophie sur youtube à ce moment-là
cyrus north typiquement plutôt une
approche ont déjà beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins approfondie est beaucoup
plus orienté sur les hauteurs et donc on
était assez différente ce pont du las
voilà je sais pas trop quoi dire de plus
j'éprouve ennuyer les gens rencontre
avec lycée qui est plutôt incapable de
nature et apprendre la chaîne des
explications c'est un petit live or
c'est pas du style il ya quelques mois
pour savoir vent discussions et ya des
gens qui vous des photos soir voilà
s'est réalisé grâce aux graphismes et
j'ai pas du tout citer deux jours
précisément c'était cela le col et comme
le disait cyrus north
je m'abonne toi tous blueberry you see
you cfi désole me disait platon et
socrate
moi j'avais une question qui découle est
un peu tout ça maintenant que vous avez
tous un peu fait vos frites preuve
qu'ils bagages sur différents domaines
et angles de da proche de la médiation
s'il y avait un conseil un seul que
devait donner à quelqu'un qui veut se
lancer
ça serait quoi selon vous vous pouvez
prendre par exemple une difficulté que
vous avez à l'affronter et vous êtes dit
comment je m'en suis sortie et ça peut
être pas sur la gestion de temps sur
commence à taxer à quelqu'un je sais pas
si on conseille que nous donnerait sait
que je donnerai c'est prendre soin de sa
motivation est souvent une façon de
prendre soin de sa motivation c'est de
ne pas être trop perfectionniste parce
que c'est facile de rester des mois sur
un truc les en fait on se décourage pas
et dans ce sens là tu pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui aimeraient se
lancer qui se lancent pas parce qu'ils
ont trop peur de patte à ses paroles qui
vendent la première vidéo youtube c'est
de la merde
pas grave si l'on a des
c'est pas viser clairement vidéo il faut
que la vidéo soit une bonne pièce faut
s'habituer à produire et puis ça va
venir en faisant bon moi je pense à un
truc qui est sympa c'est de se dire
qu'on va apprendre des choses se motiver
au départ en disant que c'est un
ensemble de compétences que je vais
acquérir que ce soit moi en l'occurrence
les plus hauts des trucs techniques du
jour j'allais pas monter une vidéo avant
de me lancer dans les premières on
apprend ça et dans tous les cas où ça
peut être parce que tu vas apprendre des
trucs sur le sujet que régulariser tout
cas il ya moyen de se motiver au départ
parce que tu apprends du de la démarche
de vulgarisation et bien sûr regardé sa
chaîne principale pour la france c'est
que tout le monde n'est pas en tant qu'
on ne fait pas le métier de nom mais
justement moi je suis un peu le je pense
je suis l'exception de cette table
d'ailleurs moi je parlais d'imposture
tout à l'heure mais vous parlera qui a
le mois du conseil du coup je donnerai
c'est bien du survivant enfin en gros ça
se résume à ça c'est attendais pas ne
vous mettez pas des objectifs on va dire
trop inatteignable où il réalise pensais
pas que ce sera facile si vous cherchez
le le chiffre évidemment tout le monde
je pense veut être diffusée tout le
monde veut avoir un certain nombre de
vues ce qu'on communique pas pour
personne évidemment ça veut toujours
atteindre en plus de monde à avoir un
impact c'est évident juste soyez
conscients que la masse de créateurs sur
quelle que soit la plateforme sur
internet est énorme et que en gros
très certainement vous serez pendant
longtemps un random parmi les rangs
d'hommes comme je le suis je suis
toujours d'ailleurs peut-être la
différence entre sparrow d'homs et ceux
qui persistent way assayas à ce que la
5è si vous persistez pas ça ira pas plus
loin
non c'est sûr donc déjà blindé vous de
motivation mais même il
faites le pour vous déjà ce projet est
pas pour grand chose à ma motivation
ouais voilà c'est ça c'est que faites le
avant tout pour la passion ne cherchez
pas des objectifs inatteignables en
termes de diffusion d'audience de ce
corps ça se soyez juste content de faire
ce que vous faites sans vous sans vivre
à travers ça et sans vous prendre la
tête quand vous atteignez pas ce que
vous voulez atteindre quand je pense que
prenez du recul vis-à-vis de ça des
scores des nombres de vue et c'est parce
que sinon ça va vous bouffer en fait et
vous allez juste dire mais je fais un
minable je fais rien je fais je fais pas
de sport ch pourquoi les autres marchent
je mérite pas
ouais il ya beaucoup de gens et parce
que en fait france rend pas compte mais
il ya du coup un énorme bien on
s'attache à aux gens qui réussissent
bien et vous êtes un peu des modèles je
pense pour beaucoup de gens parce que
vous avez la norme et vous êtes
relativement relativement que lyon va
venir les gens déjà entendu parler de
vous une de vos vidéos et donc et on
s'adore on s'attache à ça c'est super
parce que ça permet de beaucoup de
soi-même créer de se dire j'aimerais
attendre un peu car ce qu'ils font mais
sachez que c'est très difficile en tant
que nouveaux créateurs de contenu de
faire la différence et de percer on va
dire entre guillemets certains y
arrivent
il ya des gens des fois on les voit
personne mais en fait la masse c'est la
majorité des gens sont dans le dans le
flou un peu et on n'arrive pas je suis
un exemple parmi tant d'autres mais
voilà c'était juste faire attention à ça
ne pas non plus trop donner d'espoir à
des nouveaux créateurs qui voudraient
chercher directement le danois je veux
bien parce que j'ai dit là je vois bien
l'image du mec qui veut apprendre le
vélo tu as genre je vais te casser la
gueule ça va être long tu vas encore
casser la gueule mais il faut continuer
parce qu'une tumeur du vélo se fait
choisir et j'aurais passé petit d'herbe
de leur histoire de casser la gueule
c'est au contraire les premières vidéos
cents à prendre free sera torah appris
ça tu auras aux 6es
c'est ce truc que trois produits et u2
sera fier
et je pense que je veux dire si les
vingt mois j'étais prof quand je parlais
s'il vend 30 personnes max quand j'avais
sur une année j'avais peut-être pas 100
élèves une vidéo elle fait rapidement
son but mine de rien donc on se rend
compte des chiffres sont 300 fait vraie
valeur de 500 bus avait 30 personnes
si je peux ajouter un truc c'est bien
aussi de savoir bien s'entourer que ce
soit soit d'autres créateurs ou d'autres
gens qui font des trucs un peu pareil
pour bah justement se motive les uns des
autres on se donne des conseils
et puis ne pas hésiter aussi à envoyer
notre vidéo d'inscrire notre script à à
d'autres gens que ce soit soit des
experts en relecture ça est vachement
points pour faire taire un peu syndrome
de l'imposteur
ou alors même des vidéastes pour leur
demander des conseils leur demander leur
avis et tout ça permet de on essaie
d'aider les gens c'est le bateau tape
les objectifs conscience inscrivez-vous
parce que c'est gratuit et qui font
plein de choses super chouette
non c'est un troisième exemplaire de
troisième numéro de cefalu ce qui va
bien tout ça alors alors je demande que
vous quittez ça et que vous lui envoyez
oui il ya le café des sciences donc et
une association que vous connaissez
peut-être deux
vulgarisateur scientifique dont on fait
tous partie là je crois oui le collectif
conscience fait partie du café aussi et
ils ont mis en place notamment des
groupes facebook de relecture de scripts
ou d'articles de blogs par des experts
donc ces thématiques
vous pouvez entrer en contact avec les
gens du café pour avoir le lien tout le
monde peut aller dessus et le principe
c'est que l'on pose son script ou ou son
article ou je sais pas quoi et à ce
moment là les gens peuvent le relire
donné des retours au chant et c'est
vachement cool mais avant tout ce que je
me dis oui non c'est juste en
complémentaire
loïc et / ou à lens est parti donc
petite question de quartz qui est très
longue et très lent on est actuellement
sur twitch pour faire un live
est-ce que vous pensez que ce média de
communication et de science et de la
réflexion a du potentiel face aux
podcasts et à youtube on va s'arrêter là
un plat on peut parler une heure le fait
de ne pas pouvoir éditer rajouter c'est
vrai que c'est pas du tout le même
exercice après je pense qu'il ya aussi
peut-être pas forcément les mêmes
publics et je vois par exemple un
podcast tu vas pouvoir l'écouter en
sorte à vaisselle en ce sens que tu veux
tu vas fin avec c'est une vidéo tab 2
ans quand même des fois de te poser dans
les relais de la tension un live t'as
plus envie de le vivre comme tout est en
train de le vivre actuellement je pense
que chaque média aussi ses spécialités
et donc ils peuvent chacun perd ses
médecins lui aussi faire de la matière
pour des vidéos comme ce petit monde rit
c'est pas du sel quand je vois les les
expériences de groupes de musique
envahit les expériences de bruzy corps
qui sont très visuel etc
si tu as de la bonne qualité tu peux
faire comme le font déjà les streamer
faire des trucs plus coupés et cetera
donc il ya quand même le principe c'est
plus compliqué à monter vu que souvent
tu as moins de deux plans entre les deux
parce que c'est plus mais il ya quand
même de la matière à faire de la vidéo
mais je pense quand même pour la
je pense quand même que s'il ya un vrai
avenir à la médiation scientifique pour
le lay parce que on peut créer une
ambiance totalement différente d'une
vidéo et que le fait d'être en live ça
décourage moins que de regarder une
vidéo de 3 à faire prendre le temps là
on peut prendre le temps et les gens
peuvent venir passer la garantie vol etc
et il ya vraiment plein de moyens
différents acteurs est typiquement bat
robin à une informatique allemand
différent du nôtre mais pourtant c'est
laid je pense que des choses qui se
complaît c'est nous on est plus dans on
est tous autour d'une table on discute
on rigole et c est là c'est un petit peu
plus sérieux mais ça reste comme ça
reste quand même très agréable et très
très très divertissant comptes réguliers
merci kaïs est parce que j'aime bien que
sa forme à celle vraiment côté
interaction directe avec c'est ça c'est
ça qu'on postule pas beaucoup faire
quand on quand on fait des vidéos sur
youtube au personnel en fait moi je
pense qu'il ya deux grandes forces à
alive par rapport à la vod c'est
l'interaction ce que tu dis est le
deuxième c'est la spontanéité le naturel
le pas couper le pain faux parce que
voilà c'est ça les gens ils recherchent
ça aussi l'authenticité exactement de
voir les choses directement et tu peux
pas là si je dis là le noir c'est
terminé enfin bon on est dans dans
l'instantanéité est dans le vrai quoi
les gens aiment beaucoup ça parce qu'en
plus ils du coup ils peuvent interagir
il peut créer des liens du coup c'est un
média complètement différent je sais pas
si on va en reparler mais le live et du
rêve et c'est assez simple mais si la
partie comme disait
le live ea le côté aussi un vidéaste où
tout est que tu es où tout est où quand
on leur explique ce que ça le live et
donna alors le racing voit des gars qui
essaient de lancer une chaîne et ça
c'est largement foiré n'hésitez pas à
google et c'est très marrant à ils ont
fait tout ce qu'il fallait qu'elle soit
supprimée ballon mais après on va pas
trop s'attarder dessus mais surtout je
pense je trouvais que sa réflexion était
très bref dans le sens où lui
l'escrimeur il voit très bien que quand
et vidéaste t'as pas forcément le même
fonctionnement qu'un présentateur
n'était pas forcément un bon
présentateur parce que il ya tout un
truc que quand tu peux que t'es plein de
trucs quand tu peux enlever tout est
blanc quand tu peux recommencer mais
c'est plus facile à faire c'est plus
évident parce que voilà tu peux c'est un
vrai on traîne un vrai travail d'édition
mais quand est on là tu peux pas
vraiment de foirer ou alors en tout cas
faut pas avoir peur de squares et les
premières fois et reprendre c'est
quelque chose qui s'apprend aussi à être
présentateur est naturel quoi et vous
est-ce que vous aviez vous auriez envie
de faire du live moi j'ai une expérience
de là il va rester extrêmement bizarre
celle ci j'ai fait sur ma chaîne vidéo
que ça plein effet du fait des maths
c'est une vidéo incroyablement choquant
ou littéralement je fais des mad au
tableau en plus à camara ya six mois
donc on voit pas très bien le tableau et
j'explique pas du tout ce que je fais
mais je pensais que bizarrement j'ai
quand même une certaine attente bizarre
que non pas
il ya eu mille personnes en live alors
que c'était un lundi à 14h et la vidéo
d'un autre 12000 vu les choses comme ça
et pourtant à croix blanche mais ça
vient celui de l'authenticité ou envoi
mathématiques en train de faire des
matches ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
vu quelques petites idées de cette vidéo
un peu
même joie route et même refaire un truc
du même genre ce que tu as vu la cour de
de rétention mais il ya quand même 5 %
qui a jusqu'au bout de 5 % de 12 mais ça
fait cet avis est c'est très con ça fait
qu'il ya vraiment des pics de vue à
certains trucs et donc évidemment
personne ne va voir les les trois heures
de vidéo en entier tout de suite parce
que c'est comme rennes de voir le le
numéro dé l'art de bâtir sur les formats
très long donc oui il se trouve que sa
chaîne principale à des formes assez
long m
un peu pour tout le monde c'est à dire
est aussi des formations et du coup
c'est déjà interdit de penser c'est
juste audio quoi vais je pense comme les
voir des gens écoutent ça en faisant
autre chose que visuellement axiome
c'est pas du live mais on se retrouve
quasiment se déroule à tourner en live
ça nous arrive est différent est bon il
ya ça trouve un public mais ça que j'ai
des solutions
pas du tout à l'aise à l'accès à la base
je préfère faire de vie des autres et
monter tout ça je suis pas dire je fais
pas sur tweets ou super une course on a
tort de ça donc c'est partout que je
comprends trop mais voilà alors ne dit
pas bonjour c'est un truc qui si vous
comparez pas je consomme des vidéos
tweet je serais quelque chose pourquoi
pas faudra avoir une bonne connexion
corps mais j'ai des petites idées du tea
est ce que c'est
dans steam décembre après ce que tu
décides oui c'est clair en train fou de
vous les donner et il ya tous les plats
nos pieds sont en bas si vous suivez
nous et vous pouvez aussi vous abonner
ou envoyer des pics non non non je suis
la tannerie en prison mais voilà si vous
voulez vous pouvez tout est en bas tout
ce qu'il ya où vous c'est sur le social
voilà je suis mais je vais demander
quels soutiens ici pour vous abonner
gratuitement à la note de rien les
petits pots si oui il ya un an et en
asie pub du tgv doit jouer ses facultés
pour bâle le avec quelques petits trucs
dessus ça y est je donne l'adresse
a--t-il point llose la chiasse de
comptoir faudra bien qu'on atteigne 10
auparavant le récent le percement c'est
tout mais sinon ouais j'ai demandé c'est
quoi ton expérience dans une rédaction
parce que tu es journaliste du travail à
sion c'est l'avenir oui égaler la
différence justement entre les vidéos on
a media et la ville et vidéos la
médiation directe que tu fais parfois
d'or par exemple avec ton ton rock
taille ou ton bar à cocktails voilà est
la différence avec genre le
fonctionnement du nombre d'actions et
comment tu fais tes articles etc
oui est-ce que je peux reprendre la
contrainte pour répond alors j'espère
explique un peu le bar à cailloux c'est
un truc que j'avais fait à une
convention à toulouse je sais plus quand
c'était la dernière fois non ouais voilà
parti comme il assuré mais je voyais ça
dépend encore les gens regardent la
vidéo à date et du coup c'était en fait
j'ai expliqué la formation de des
différentes des différents types de
roches avec des cocktails et les gens
jeu forcé les gens à boire des cocktails
après c'était gênant pour tout le monde
voilà le créca effectivement il ya des
vidéos et puis à mes vidéos m alors les
vidéos pour un média que je fais c'est
plus dû au fil de l'eau je m'en veux
dire en gros bas c'est des trucs ça
débite beaucoup plus vite et que que des
vidéos pour moi donc je peux pas me
permettre de faire des effets spéciaux
de malades d'autres comme ça ça fait à
peu près cette finale ouais c'est enfin
moi beaucoup plus traditionnels même si
j'ai essayé des trucs j'ai tenté d face
caméra il voit la fin au fur et à mesure
je fais et ça marche et d'apathie
donc on voit ma tête soit 707 dans des
situations gènes associés à 17h10 oui
mais ce n'est pas ce contexte j'avais
tenté on a reçu 1 le dernier samsung
l'attesté smartphones et je me suis bien
je fais une vidéo unboxing parce que
c'est un pas l'air bien de compliqué en
fait rien ne va dans la vidéo est floue
j'arrive pas à l'ouvrir même avec un
cutter les meilleurs et du coup je me
dis que les jeunes boxeurs triche
forcément il ouvre la boîte avant parce
que oui bah forcément
ou alors ils ont du talent je suis là on
est forcément mais aussi ils ont
travaillé leur set up au cours du temps
c'est à dire dont il a maintenant les
trucs en boxe thérapies dont 120 46
caméra genre en haut ou en bas devant
derrière etc
ils ont le truc bien blanc externe oui
c'est vrai mais c'est comme tout au
final c'est c'est il ya des trucs très
c'est ça peut être très spécialisés oui
tout à fait et dewey pour pour les
vidéos que je fais pour ce média
en fait on fait par exemple on peut
faire des reportages des trucs comme ça
ça ne demande pas mal de temps de
montage et après quand on fait des
interviews on peut faire des interviews
fleuves qui durant une demi-heure une
heure ça dépend et après on les découpe
en plein de petites donc ça un tournage
ça peut me faire six à dix vidéos
mannequin c'est pas le même travail
qu'une vidéo youtube
même si ça demande quand même beaucoup
de boulot derrière et berthe à voyager
cet été
justement pour ton travail oui j'ai pris
des petites vacances ouais j'ai fait un
petit tour je suis allé en suisse pour
un congrès de journalistes scientifiques
c'est ce que les romans de jeu mais
l'armée y alors vous n'avez pas cité le
reste c'était en face d'eux le pfl
l'école politique est là et du coup il
ya un article qui est sorti de sa qui
vient justement d'une table ronde de
participer de l'est sur youtube et les
fake news et dont vous pouvez voir sur
le site de sciences et avenir c'est
facebook youtube
au royaume des faits keynews un truc
comme ça on a pris extrêmement
intéressant je compte les données
pourquoi j'ai commencé cette phrase oui
donc la suisse je suis allé en russie
aussi pour aller filmer diverses choses
et notamment comment on fabrique le
pétrole comment ils se forment donc pas
et vous tapez comment se forme le
pétrole vous pouvez voir une petite
vidéo que j'ai fait mais aussi au siège
du total locale c'était fantastique
il valait diverses et autres choses qui
sont pas encore en ligne
c'est ben oui il ya quelque chose que tu
as fait d'ici le entre le deuxième entre
le deuxième c'est pas juste notre invité
à sortir un documentaire
ouais j'ai sorti un mon premier
documentaire qui s'appelle le mystère de
l'expansion des tropiques et il se
trouve que voilà j'ai eu l'occasion de
partir en patagonie à suivre des
biologistes qui a étudié les anneaux de
croissance des arbres sur place donc en
argentine dans la cordillère dans la
cordillère des andes et j'ai découvert
qu'il y avait une espèce de problème
j'ai découvert pas moins qu'il n'en
voilà donc qu'on a ce qu'on appelle le
mystère de l'expression des tropiques
qui est ce phénomène climatique qui fait
que beaucoup de zones en dehors de la
zone tropicale juste juste qu'à poser à
la zone tropicale sacrifie au fil du
temps et donc on a des déserts comme le
désert du sahara qui au cours du dernier
siècle augmenter sa surface de 10 % et
ça commence à poser problème pour les
populations qui sont dans ces zones la
houle avec le climat change très vite et
pour la biodiversité évidemment et en
fait on ne sait pas à quel point c'est
dû aux activités humaines parce que en
fait les activités humaines depuis des
centaines d'années par depuis au moins
deux cents ans on aimait énormément de
décès dans l'atmosphère ont changé la
composition de l'atmosphère etc
mais c'est aussi à ce moment là on
commence à voir les premières mesures de
climat voilà et les premières son
premier recours de la composition de
l'atmosphère et donc c'est très
difficile de savoir qu'est ce qu'il y
avait avant
les activités humaines d'où l'intérêt
d'aller piocher dans les arbres faire
des trous dans les armes à faire avec un
énorme tient bon fond d'écran des
carottes pour aller voir qu'est ce qui
se passe et 9 100 ans l'an passé en
termes d'humidité de température etc et
donc je suis pu suivre des gens qui font
un travail absolument fou qui vont
en plein dans pleine jungle de patagonie
pour découper des arbres et puis et puis
les couper à la main avec leurs petits
scalpel pour faire passer les doctorants
qui font ça et 1 et donc voilà donc
c'est un sujet je connaissais pas du
tout donc j'ai eu l'occasion de faire ça
complètement par hasard parce que j'ai
pu bosser avec une boîte string theory
qui fait avec qui j'ai bossé pendant et
après c'était un peu le hasard la chance
qui a fait que j'ai pu j'ai pu faire ça
mais ça fait longtemps que je voulais
faire du vrai documentaire quoi c'est
quelque chose que moi je consomme
énormément et j'étais content de pouvoir
me confronter à ce genre de contraintes
bon sachant que j'ai eu une semaine et
demie pour pouvoir l'écrire sur un sujet
que je connaissais pas du tout à la base
donc donc ça a été assez intense
j'ai une question par rapport à la
production cette vidéo là à quel niveau
tu as travaillé donc tu parles de
l'écriture à ce que tu avais aussi fait
tout le montage ça commence alors c'est
ça qui est bien et toi tu es quand tu
passes avec une boîte de prod c'est que
tu peux te permettre à arriver avec en
direct en stricte à toi ton rôle c'est
de présenter d'incarner le documentaire
et après il ya toute une équipe derrière
qui qui est autour de toi alors nous
avons travaillé avec chez pas une à peu
près une dizaine de personnes a un petit
peu moins d'une dizaine de personnes
donc il y avait des gens qui prenaient
psoe avait des gens qui faisaient le
cadrage et des gens qui y réaliser les
images et y avait des gens qui montait
tout ça est donc alors moi j'ai pas j'ai
pas vu le 28 10 on nous envoie des
versions montage aux différents tons moi
je peux faire des retours et serra et un
réal quoi ouais je les ai vus à la fin
et confiance pour ça c'est cool sinon à
koutal à la liberté d'écrire depuis j'ai
pu dire ce que je roule avec moi donc je
suis assez content je sais qu'on tend ce
niveau là et content je voulais parler
de changement climatique en plus c'est
un sujet qui me porte
mais voilà ça me fait ça me permet de
faire un pont sur ce genre de sujets là
et et voilà donc ça ma part c'est
évidemment mais je compte en queue de ce
qu'on a fait jusqu'à présent
une grosse liberté ah oui j'avais une
totale liberté bien pour le coup il y
avait des contraintes temporelles après
j'étais très content d'avoir accès à
l'équipe scientifique
il était directement lié à tout ça parce
qu'ils ont pu relire mes street et voilà
changer voire des petites erreurs que
j'aurais pas eu forcément
et voilà donc donc c'était cool les
bâillons ksa suis là en masse merci à
lauriad et c'est fabrice mais yahia les
qui nous a parlé de ce qu'ils
prévoyaient de faire déjà un peu près ce
que je voulais savoir si toi tu as des
projets dans les tuyaux pour alors j'ai
invité à sortir en est non bizarrement
mais tout c'est un livre qui va parler
d'histoire de la philosophie et voilà
c'est sympa je suis content et quoi
d'autre sinon danon sur ma chaîne ça va
continuer et c'est bien voilà il ya un
truc qui va un peu vite mais globalement
voilà la chaîne va continuer et puis je
vais sortir un livre
et voilà pour l'essentiel via belhocine
et easy soit un potentiel projet twitch
non non non non c'est pas d'embryons
j'attends la fibre d'abord robin par
contre as tu des idées de streaming tu
as déjà essayé un truc là lundi dès
lundi selon m où tu voulais faire un
masque est en même temps que ta
conférence quelles sont tes retour
justement basse et voix lasse et j'ai
voulu tenter un format qui à mon sens
n'existe pas sur twitch mais peut-être
que ça a eu existé où ça existe et je
suis pas au courant c'est de faire du
live catching en même temps qu'une
conférence avec deux personnes en fait
donc deux comptes which le mien où je
fais où j'invite
je parle avec mon invité et quelqu'un
d'autre un dessinateur qui a second site
oui cela et qui avec qui bat du coup on
pourrait se mettre en squad c'est un
outil de streaming qui existe sur twitch
ou ou en fait pour le viewer ils voient
les peut voir les deux strips là un
stream principal qui voit où il a guy la
leçon et il peut naviguer du stream à
l'autre de manière très facile
l'interface est fait en fait pour que ça
soit pour que ce soit fait voilà que ça
soit regardable pour pour les pour le
viewer lambda on va dire et donc je
voulais tenter ça avec un ami que c'est
un très bon ami qui est dessinateur et
donc ils avaient jusque récemment sa
chaîne tweet juste pour ça et
malheureusement l'option du stream squad
sur twitch n'est possible que quand on
est partenaires c'est un statut
particulier il faut avoir tant d'abonnés
étant de stats et c'est qu'on n'a pas pu
faire ça mais il ya un outil auxiliaires
qui s'appelle le multi twitch qui permet
sur une page web d'afficher les deux les
deux stream donc j'ai pu quand même
faire ça mais c'est moins c'est moins
d'optimiser bref j'ai tenté un truc qui
a pas eu un succès franc à cause de ce
tout petit lac est pas très maniable
mais je pense que avec le squad stream
si on l'avait si on pouvait la voir
ça pourrait être pas mal parce qu'en
fait du coup ça donnerait vraiment cette
possibilité aux joueurs de voir du live
kitchen en même temps que la conf et
choisir son sont ceux qui voient en fait
donc apporter encore une plus value au
lieu de voir un peu le powerpoint par
exemple où mon invité parle si mon
invité fait juste du dialogue et
qu'enfin juste parler qu'il n'a pas
besoin du powerpoint par exemple parce
que ça s'éternise le viewer peut passer
sur le
le dessin et c'est d'autant plus
intéressant
et du coup c'est pas mal parce que ça
concilie l'art et la science le principe
du life coaching évidemment mais là pour
le coup c'est au niveau du live tweet ch
enfin c'est au niveau d'internet
donc voilà c'est un concept que manger
je connais personne qui ait déjà fait ça
sur la plateforme mais voilà c'est un
truc à creuser et à optimiser encore et
voilà j'espère que je sais pas comment
je vais faire mais je pense que je vais
envoyer un mail à twitch pour avoir ce
genre de scènes parfois pour le en
attendant d'avoir un truc stable de
chrome os son flux genre il le met
directement sur focalise alors las le
flux vidéo en fait le problème actuel et
les plus techniques
ouais les russes technique parce que je
fais mais mes conférences sur skype avec
mon invité et donc il faudrait que je
sois avec mon invité et avec le
dessinateur et que les deux me partage
leur écran un autre compte twitch à
parcé
c'est sympa parce que le gars de son
côté il peut amener les artistes et moi
j'ai moi j'amène le plutôt le côté
scientifique et du coup ça rallye des
communautés est plutôt que ça soit moi
qui gère tous que l'on soit plutôt
séparé que chacun fasse son truc comme
ça il peut aussi lancer son live quand
je suis pas là et faire ses dessins et
inversement si les palins soir moi je
peux juste faire du live scientifique
fin voilà avoir plus de jeu c'est pas
vrai que chacun soit un peu plus
indépendante quoi sur son contenu et que
ben voila ca ca permettent aussi on
travaille en collaboration quand on veut
mais oui oui c'est enfin pour le moment
on est encore dans le champ des
possibles il faut juste avoir la
technologie la technique qui va bien et
qu'on essaye tout simplement aller voir
si ça plaît aux gens et si on a des bons
retours pour lancer très expérimentale
la communauté voilà j'ai pas beaucoup de
follower encore j'en ai un petit peu
plus de 200 et jérôme hutin
venez-vous la chaîne sait tous qu'on
prend d'ailleurs
eh ben on là il veut dire à peu près
entre 20 et 30 personnes en général mais
live donc bouger et puis tout le monde
ne participe pas dans le chat donc
forcément y'a pas forcément des retours
mais voilà j'espère que sur le long
terme et j'arriverai à optimiser le truc
et avoir mon verra si ça marche pas
parlant des je suis heureux de les
prononcer mais à demain à priori il y
aura un live sur wow on va faire un
voyou tube c'est sur youtube
si ça marche quand je garantirai faire
un jeu mais l'idée c'est de faire les
équipes et ça paye qcmmmm bayésiens ils
vont avoir commandé avec des jld ont
déjà dit oui doses déjà dit oui même si
le savent pas et c'est le live sur la
chaîne youtube de la nuit oui oui mais
en plus tu as commencé le live lors
complètement avec un autre coup bah
ouais non mais moi j'aime pas faire les
choses faciles tu vois donc l'idée alors
le pitch setec c'était les 80 ans du
cnrs l'année dernière et mon labo dans
lequel je postais avant de quitter la
recherche m'a appelé pour me dire c'est
bon ça te dit d'animer
voilà de nîmes et un live de 12 heures à
l'occasion du 80 des 80 heures de stage
à toi donc on a fait la nuit de
l'astronomie alors ils savaient pas trop
dans quoi on s'embarque pas ce qu'il
n'avait jamais fait ça moi non plus du
coup on s'est dit bas allons-y
mais qu'est ce qui peut se passer et
donc c'était très sympa on a pu pendant
alors l'idée c'était d'avoir une nuit
complète de conférences différentes qui
sont aujourd'hui disponibles sur la
chaîne sur le senso frondeur et avec des
time code et tout mais on avait des lay
sketcher du café des sciences qui il a
scotché les conférences en direct et la
fin de mon rôle c'était beau rôle celui
d'étienne et il y avait la liste de la
chaîne
alice au pays des étoiles et et sophie
félix du collectif conscience qui est
vice-président notre présidente à tous
et du coup elle a l'idée c'était de
tenir une nuit complète pour parler de
sciences pour interagir avec le public
qui soit on y avait 700 personnes à
l'institut d'astrophysique de paris ce
qui était du jamais vu en fait il y
avait des gens qui faisaient deux heures
de queue à l'extérieur pour venir
donc ça a eu un vrai succès on a eu
quelque chose comme 20 mille personnes
sur le live
15000 à la fin du live en tout avec des
pics et à 700 800 personnes donc on
était assez agréablement surpris et du
coup on va on va retenter l'expérience
en juin alors ne sera pas à lire et
cette fois ce sera alors je sais plus
comment ça s'appelle mais ce sera à
palaiseau et en pas à palaiseau à orsay
pardon et dans la ville d'orsay ils
veulent faire un festival qui
s'appellera du big bang au big bands et
l'idée c'est de combiner des conférences
scientifiques qui seront données par des
astrophysiciens et des astrophysiciens
locaux donc de la fac d'orsay et des
concerts de jazz et il y aura plein
d'animations un petit peu partout et du
las reaching et donc on est on est en
fin de compte verser 1 à l'heure
actuelle on essaie de faire quelque
chose de plus vivant possible qui
mélange vraiment arts et sciences donc
c'est parfait que lorsque tu fais la
cible et est donc voila ce sera en juin
je sais plus exactement quand je mets
mon assez hâte de faire ça alors moi je
ne suis pas du tout du tout live en fait
je suis plutôt là pour pour l'expérience
du truc jeu mais voilà de sortir de ma
zone de confort c'est vraiment ce que je
préfère j'aime bien j'aime bien le même
mais à voir la lidc de ces de promouvoir
un petit peu bas des chercheurs qui font
qu'ils font la science c'est qu'ils
parlent directement avec du public ça ce
j'ai bien parlé mais j'aime bien aussi
laissé la parole à des gens qui
s'amusent mois déjà ça de même
l'impression et puis ça me permet de
partager de la science et de faire
découvrir des nouvelles têtes quoi et
enfin la balade - c est pour ça je
trouve ça très important la question de
la représentativité dans la science et
de l'image qu'on donne de la science et
le fait que voilà que ce soit pas juste
moi homme blanc
deux classes moyennes qui parle de
science ensuite forcé à dire asiatiques
pour s'exercer pour l'auteur donc voilà
mais en parlant de live enfin moi je
pense ou quand on pense à tout est sûre
on pense d'abord aux jeux vidéo tu vois
et à l'amener aux playes à surfer ciani
aussi toute une section jeux vidéo que
je me baladais un moment donné je me
suis dit mais en fait on pourra aussi
vous demander genre est ce que vous vous
êtes des joueurs de jeux vidéo et si oui
non peut importe parce que vous avez
déjà pensé essayer de faire un truc de
médiation avec des jeux aussi c'est déjà
fait et que j'aurai raté qui commence
je dirais pas non plus énorme entre eux
mais en fait l'idée médias traversé
l'esprit quand je cherchais des concepts
sur twitch affaires comme le jeu vidéo
et comme tu dit extrêmement présente en
fait semaine même déjà arrivé en jouant
à des jeux batipart witcher où il ya de
l'alchimie par exemple il ya côté chimie
où tu repères des trucs du coût des
concepts scientifiques qui sont plus ou
moins en rapport avec la réalité et tu
repères aussi les clins d'oeil à des à
des faits historiques ou à des
scientifiques quoi des choses comme ça
et du coup on aurait cette approche en
faisant nous scientifiques en ce genre
de truc qu'on aurait une approche plus
value par rapport à des gens qui n'ont
pas forcément ce background
donc voilà je réfléchissais à
éventuellement un concept sur twitch de
faire le stream est en train de jouer
mais un jeu qui dans lequel je sais ya
un potentiel scientifique de discussion
autour de sujets pourraient pour en
parler mais ce sera l'esprit me préparer
à ce moment là ça serait pas je prends
un jeu au pif que j'aime bien je joue et
puis je réfléchirai quand même un peu à
la au sujet je voudrais aborder un peu
amour jouer et parler en même temps
et bien sûr mais je pourrais faire un
bon un bon duo enfin c'est du
divertissement restaurer du
divertissement et en faisant passer voit
le côté des techniques scientifiques
aiment leur pilule comme ça moi j'ai une
vidéo sur la chaîne qui fait alors c'est
un jeu un jeu un peu particulier c'est
un jeu il s'appelle universal plug in
[Musique]
est en fait un jeu qui est inspiré d'une
expérience de pensée en philosophie de
nikos tron et qui est sur une
intelligence artificielle super
puissante et du coup j'ai essayé
d'imiter parce que je suis pas du tout
du milieu je joue pas beaucoup jeu vidéo
mais bon j'ai fait de mon mieux mais
finement a non seulement film ans que je
joue mais aussi en rajoutant des
explications pourquoi est ce que il se
passe là dans ce jeu qu'est ce que ça
représente un produit ou intelligence
artificielle
c'est ma principale expérience ici
ensuite il faudra invité pour parler de
ça c'est david o ici notre part ajouté
cia est en cours si on peut parler de
jeux vidéo mais c'est un concours en
ligne avec des petits jeux qui s'appelle
le concours al kindi qu'a été lancé en
france depuis quelques années donc c'est
pour les de 4e 3e et 2nde et 5 jamais
fait de faim si j'ai fait une vidéo qui
expliquait le concours mais ça peut être
aussi marrant de faire une vidéo où on
joue au jeu du coupon typiquement pour
les jeux vidéo qui s'y prêtent
oui surtout que le deuxième va sortir
oui on a un petit problème de connexion
c'est pas grave ça revient ça revient
tranquillement mais ouais c'est
typiquement dans ton traîner dans le
festival salève mais je disais karbal en
fait car bâle est assez intéressant
parce qu'il ya une physique qui quand
même qui reste comme assez réaliste
norman a dragué longue file s'est
densifié que je travaille c'est très
intéressant parce que ça permet à la
fois de faire des trucs marrants où tu
peux tout faire exploser
et en même temps en même temps tu peux
vraiment parler de pourquoi tu déconne
comme ça comment tu fais pour te
satellisé etc
et je pense qu'il ya vraiment un
potentiel latent
après c'est sûr que prendre le temps et
puis je pense qu'il faut pas se lancer
même si on fait un truc de jeux vidéo
genre scientiques genre avec il ya un
lien avec les sciences faut quand même
garder pas par moi j'aimerais quand même
garder un lien avec la sueur c'est un
peu organisés en mode bastien si on
arrive à ça je pense qu'il faudrait
comme un petit peu parlé de ça avoir des
points terrain avoir des points
principaux
jean romain et de se préparer un peu et
on peut pas faire en fait si on veut
parler science avec un jeu vidéo on peut
pas faire comme les streamer qui peuvent
lancer en live tout bas en live comme ça
là veulent pas un genre à la va-vite
genre quand ils ont envie et se dit
impatient ou je dirai ce que je veux là
si on veut parler science on peut
totalement joué un jeu vidéo super
problème mais si on veut parler sinon je
pense qu'il faut vraiment préparé un peu
revoir était typiquement tout ce qui est
mécanique de rica etc
j'ai aussi une vidéo d'antan genre sur
ma chaîne là je redécouvre mes vidéos en
réseau c'est ça ok moi j'avais posé une
énigme
il ya une deux étoiles qui tournait
autour de l'autre il y en a une qui
explose qu'est-ce qui se passe et puis
la yamaha débat lui le geek qui a
commencé à faire des simulations sur ces
univers ce n'est pas vraiment le psg a
lui dit c'est le gros le broc depuis les
faits la simulation et puis bon ben
c'est du matériel du coup on a un peu
comblé un peu les maths et les
simulations pour les fils de ce fait
débat les images c'était un truc moi
j'ai pas lui qui je suis pas très jeune
mais très clair mal perso parce que le
côté bac à sable par la hausse voilà
j'ai besoin d'une histoire qui ont joué
avec les fois où il ya peut-être un mode
histoire le japon qui va progressivement
où tu dois aborder en fait tu ta
démission clés comme moi donc c'est
juste que tu ne toute la famille tarabin
une grosse narration c'est que la
méthadone des missions clés avec ba tu
dois déjà satellisé un truc ce qui est
déjà bien compliquée et après tu me
c'est vraiment il ne s'est pas que du
bac à sable
non mais dont vous traitez pas le
premier a même conseillé car van roy je
crois qu'une bonne histoire en fait
aussi du carbone oui mais en reste
finalement il ya je crois que les
astronomiques en as trop bien sûr ouais
on a fait une victime est asservi de
n'être en effet sur sur sa chaîne
peut-être astronomique aussi je crois
possible en fait je sais qu'il ya pas
mal de gens de la sphère astros qui a
fait de la caf qui rouffet des live sur
carnac parce que ça s'y prêtait mais peu
ces jeux par contre les ai pas vus donc
je ne peux pas dire si c'était dans la
rue en faire un lien avec la science ou
juste d'en faire un truc qui étaient en
rapport avec ben parce que je voulais
rentrer en fait j'ai jamais eu
d'affinités plus que ça avec arval part
j'apprécie le concept ne s'est pas
vraiment ma came par contre j'avais
suivi naumann sky à sa sortie ouais et
j'étais absolument fan pendant les 5
premières heures pour deux filles
devenues veuves bien évidemment mais
après on vit vraiment bien meilleures et
j'avais vraiment envie de faire une
vidéo d'eux
de la physique de manuel carizza il
avait promis des planètes de la taille
de planète etc
et j'avais envie de faire de la physique
sur ces planètes la genre utiliser les
unités de vitesse un petit peu bizarre
pour pouvoir voir si on peut retourner
au même endroit avec sur la planète etc
et j'avais commencé à faire des trucs et
il se trouve que je me suis heurtée à un
problème technique c'est que j'avais
jamais fait de vidéos via ma ps4 et bah
ouais mais j'avais pas le setup et
j'avais pas les compétences pour faire
ça et en fait ça c'est ça a été tué dans
l'oeuf
alors que j'avais fait les calculs et
tout je montrerai que voilà les planètes
de nomades sky faisait quelques
kilomètres de diamètre en pratique a
connu tu n'es pas un j'ai passé un
joueur n'avait pas appelé c'est assez
assez puissante simplement j'ai une
pensée une autre vidéo sortira de
l'excellent article de nikkei
j'espère sauter sur des références sur
blessure le large avec un essai sur les
imagine société où il ya des cars et des
triangles et des carrés et tringle
s'aiment bien mais c'est ce qu'ils ont
pas envie d'être entouré de trop de gens
différents et du cou il s'appelle tous
de shillings ça vienne schelin et
j'avais fait une vidéo qui explique un
peu qui suivait aussi de tout le jeu
alors savoir que voilà les animations et
les jeux de données qui sont absolument
fantastiques fallait sur son site n 15
points me prend un point m e et on
retrouve vraiment au niveau d'aidé pour
moi c'est des animations interactives
les mieux faites du monde en fait je
trouve qu'on en aurait beaucoup à
apprendre en termes de sécurité ligne au
visuel de deux meilleures vidéos de
squeeze oui à des video game awards
game of thrones avec ce qui s'était
passé et existentielle selon la
définition de nicolas vous êtes assis
sur des chaises des tabourets pts alors
ça c'est une référence au dernier ces
phallus light ou bref vous avez fait en
gros 1
en fait tomber le poulain frères partie
son succès tels on devait choisir on
devait savoir s'ils étaient des chaises
et tabourets et c'est en fonction du
fuseau arrêté pour parler de définition
en biologie et donc ce qui fait qu'il ya
tout un foin qui l'on demande tout ça
pour vous c'est quoi etc
et donc c'était c'est assez intéressant
et là donc on devrait retrouver ça dans
la rue dans la relique et sur youtube ou
sur tout
moi je suis à peu près sûr d'être assis
entre deux chaises alors de cela ma
nièce d'accoudoirs de ces quelques
chaises c'est une chose mais on a des
vraies questions quand même ici je
voulais dire un dernier exemple sur le
jeu là j'y pense parce que c'est une
très bonne vidéo puisque je pense que
c'est un format sur lequel a que j'ai
trouvé super intéressant c'est ce que
fait le vortex où je pense vous
connaissez déjà le vortex ne serait ce
que pour les vidéos les vod enfin les
vidéos de base de youtube qui font ou
c'est une coloc de plusieurs
vulgarisateur qui parle d'un sujet mais
ils se sont mis aussi à faire des lives
en fait il invite un expert qui a parlé
d'un sujet si j'ai d'ailleurs c'est là
il va y ressemble pas mal vont bien mais
je pensais que c'était là avant d'autres
faut dire l'inversé
mais c'est sûr mais ce qui est bon
laquelle n'y a rien à voir puisque ils
ont ils en ont les moyens et c'est super
bien fait franchement je recommande à
écouter souviens je recommande d'aller
voir les lives de vortex se sont
vraiment bien ils sont très calmes et il
ya un des lives qui était sur la
médecine je crois et le un petit peu les
médecines alternatives et en quoi
justement il fallait un peu combattre
les deux sens je crois qu'il y avait
pris primum ses sacoches et banshee
rythme j'arrive pas à prononcer comment
il s'appelle personnes y arrive
en france on se retrouve un nouveau
désolé et du coup françois été invités
s'étaient l'expert de la soirée ils ont
commencé au lieu de commencer le but en
blanc sur un powerpoint puisque
d'habitude c'est ça et c'est mais moi ce
que je fais bah en fait ils ont commencé
sur assassin's creed et sur une partie
davanture d'introduction où c'est fait
c'est juste un petit chapitre où il n'ya
pas d'ennemis il n'ya pas de méchants et
rien tu étais dans une cité grecque et
tu vois les débuts de la médecine avec
avec je sais plus quel sur quel est le
médecin d'avoir besoin les lignes ans
voilà merci
hippocrate tu le rencontres en jeu il te
dit des trucs tu apprends des choses sur
les coutumes des des grecs
comment il faisait pour soigner tel ou
tel truc et ça passait tout seul et
c'est une bonne entrée en matière en
utilisant le jeu vidéo et après tu
pouvais glisser vers un truc un peu plus
voilà dur à avaler les powerpoint ou ça
au moins un attrapé ton public avec ça
et voilà je trouve c'est un excellent
exemple de l'utilisation du jeu vidéo
qui est très bien fait en live qui ont
longtemps et qui formule 1 est une
chaîne qui s'appelle tibi le fun et elle
fait beaucoup de vidéo voir et je suis
trop de bile dans touarga qui comprend
une question comme ça et c'est quand
même des vidéos qui je tiens qui n'est
pas vrai qu'une des centaines de
milliers de vues comment s'appelle la
chaîne encore ti bises et des délits b e
s
c'est notre avis parfaite transition
pour la période le mans la dernière
question du lac
ces deux questions aussi une dernière un
peu tour de table très rapidement ouais
c'est chacun d'entre vous 6 quelle
matière pour vous et ce serait sous
représentées sur youtube quelles
thématiques et si vous avez envie de
partager une jeune chaîne uni chaîne
sympa qui permettrait d'avoir un peu
plus de voix la kaaba beaucoup
d'économies hockey sur glace ils
économique c'est vraiment important et
puis il ya vraiment de la place il me
semble pour l'hexagone des sciences du
maintenant c'est quelque chose de
vraiment digéré d'être que tu aimerais
bien ça fait un bon pied seul un
diffuseur réactions j'ai le temps de
youtube accès au port casque allons-y je
regarde de moins en moins youtube
donc je regarde youtube comme
préparation de monfils a vu juste voilà
voilà
ça reste le plus ancien il est encore
les salue voilà ça c'est sûr voilà donc
c'est une chaîne qui fait la psychologie
psychologie évolutionniste on pourrait
dire alors en particulier une série de
vidéos sur la morale d'un point de vue
la psychologie en particulier de liste
et c'est super bien voilà oui les alors
un domaine qui manquent sur youtube
c'est un peu difficile comme quoi ce
n'est pas mon cas une question mais aoki
toi te manque
sinon personnellement quant à aurélien
est un jour tu as ta paix c'est le jura
galette est ce une chaîne anglophone
alors n'est quand même pas mal à essayer
de faire des trucs dont même s'il accuse
même si je trouve que n'est pas aussi
bon que j la grèce
ces vidéos et il y en a en particulier
que leur cordée qui s'appelle alexandre
techno prog avec qui a fait dans une
série récente de vidéos sur le côté
intellectuel et se motiver soi même à
vouloir être à enlever ces dissonances
cognitives à vouloir être plus honnêtes
avec nous mêmes
ah bon c'est mentir que je recommande
très vivement est doublement la chaîne
avec sandro techno prod alors le domaine
qui manquent sur youtube ben c'est la
géologie et bien sûr pas cette cailloux
il ya pas mal de paléontologie mais la
géologie piolenc a pas des masses
et il ya une petite chaîne qui est
vraiment cool bah si et ben si
c'est une petite chaîne qui s'appelle
sous nos pieds et qui parle de géologie
c'est hyper bien et la forme est hyper
belle aussi donc c'est vraiment voilà ok
moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas assez de
sciences sociales en général sur youtube
j'aimerais bien voir plus et une
citation oui peut-être mais c'est pas
grave vraiment je revendique mon choix
je pense qu'il ya pas mal de gens qui
lui aussi m oui il ya des grosses
d'invitation sont ni même si ses
exigences à ces journées sont annoncés
oui c'est moi c'est genre beaucoup
d'histoires récemment que
d'anthropologie et de sociologie etc
du coup j'aimerais bien recommander
sociologique que j'ai découvert
récemment et qui est vraiment
exceptionnel
il part toujours de référence de pop
culture pour parler de concept de
sociologie et et c'est absolument génial
enfin voila il pourrait recommander
d'autres chaînes autour des sciences
sociales notamment la chaîne game au
final
arf comme foyer et où elle elle parle de
d'écologie et de féminisme mais d'un
avec un point de vue philosophique
donc elle va faire le respect des
vitesses de vision d'ensemble des
mouvements intellectuels actuelles ou
passées autour de l'écologie et du
féminisme et c'est génial
enfin c'est vraiment très rigoureux
alors c'est pas pour tout le monde
évidemment mais c'est très très claire
pour conduire le sujet par exemple comme
des jeux dans we universum box il
faudrait plus que tu me donnes baffe
du coup je peux aussi dire que la chimie
y en a pas assez puisque c'est ça on en
a pas on n'est pas beaucoup de chaînes
donc il ya la mienne il ya celle de gala
molécules elia hambourg hébreu il ya un
raphaël blareau qui est dans lequel
finition depuis pas longtemps qui est la
personne qui représente le mieux la
chimie sur les tubes actuellement parce
qu'il ya plus de 10000 abonnés il
produit pas mal donc moi j'encouragerai
d'aller voir ce qui fait sinon ouais je
suis d'accord avec toi sur le côté des
sciences sociales et le droit en
particulier vous connaissez des chaînes
de droit qu'il fallait
ces 900 avocats sinon jouer sans si vous
connaissiez la chaîne gotha bord ou pas
ses traits c'est très particulier
je pense ce gars il est tout seul dans
son coin à faire ces trucs sa
vulgarisation
c'est très très spécial ce qui fait il
fait un peu dur roland lehoucq mais en
version hardcore enfin hyper vite hyper
rapide très le format de ces vidéos en
fait il se fait mais il se fait pas en
fait ce calme mais c'est énormément
d'extrait de même deux films de trucs il
traite d'un sujet de souvent d'une
fiction il essaye de donner une
explication il fait des calculs pour
savoir combien il faut de ballons
d'hélium pour que la maison dans up
puisque puisse tenir par exemple ça va 2
oui il y avait fait six morts et 15
blessés ni l'air entre guillemets avec
la avec star wars il parlait du concept
de la force comment à quoi pourrait
ressembler la force dans notre monde
réel quel concept filles pour être le
plus s'en approcher à ça en prenant tout
ce que disent les jedi dans les
différents épisodes il fait un condensé
d'infos et mais c'est très très speed
son rite c'est très particulier est bon
il fait ça ça marche bien et où je
trouvais ça fait mal de partager
éventuellement la foule on manque des
choses comme ça donne cette demande et
d'un euro c'est vrai que moi j'en vois
pas tant que ça oomu fabius il en faut
c'est vrai
sur ce cognitive au sens large pour la
revue aussi un truc qui manque alors
france qui n'ont pas de morts et pas mal
de maths manque peut-être un peu
d'informatique me manque de
mathématicienne et d'informaticienne et
de femmes en général sur youtube tout
simplement en parlant l'informatique on
peut proposer qu'est ce que tu dis qu
oui c'est très chouette
ils sont là vers l'ancien champion ce
soir et demain la deuxième saison demain
il est déjà nous allons faire fuir un
autre lame qui sera notre conférence
monde imaginaire donc vous devrez
choisir l'issue avec en comptant
évidemment les les gens qui seront dans
la salle on trouvera un moyen pour faire
des petits sondages des petits sondages
tout ça pour vous pour vous inclure donc
voilà on aura ce on a cette conférence
la conf et demain on va essayer on va
essayer de refaire un petit tour dans
l'état joue on essaie lives au grade
comme on l'a fait aujourd'hui voilà
en attendant vous pouvez toujours nous
suit vous abonner devant vous connaissez
la france ont donné de l'argent donné
des leçons à donner de l'argent abonnez
vous voilà et puis nous on va
probablement vous laisser voilà si vous
avez quelques questions encore les
prendre mais en attendant on va vous
laisser tranquille jadis n'est pas et
qu'on a envie de tout ça les manger
super joueur
et merci à serge merci merci merci
vraiment fixé mais l'aurait ul tu pourra
regarder la rediffusion
et si tu as mais oui je vais en temps
quelques questions dont on peut pas trop
bien je devrais y faisait fi avec pas
battant générique qui désigne comme ça
qu'est ce qu'on ferait pas comme ça oui
bonjour vous avez des questions ces
guerres civiles jour donne le ton des
plantes et estimèrent là sont réglés si
tu veux en savoir plus sur les pavés de
la cité les petites musiques qui ait
jamais eu lieu
voilà tu veux connaître les minéraux les
plus chaudes
j'avais quoi bernanos mon jeu sans
pression à demain voilà à faire le yo
m'ont dit tous au revoir
[Musique]